[Music]
from its famous access to the Mickey
Mouse Club check out when he first met
Ryan hey 18 I'm Ryan Gosling and you're
watching et bt's watching Teen Mom
stories is bothering me I Drive
let me show you something come on my
spare time I like to play ball my friend
let's talk about the Mickey Mouse let's
do it
[Music]
it was Britney and Justin and then
Christina and it was like a bootcamp on
the industry you know sort of taught us
how to be professional I remember like
one Christina where she was like 11 or
something she looked like she was eight
and a voice like I never heard in my
life just coming out of this little body
[Music]
all my friends are like in love with
Britney Spears and I just I remember
playing basketball with Britney when she
was 12 and I can't see her in a sexual
way and I kind of feel like mad when
people see her like that or talk about
it yeah yeah so with the snake around
her neck is something wrong about that
you may have started out on The Mickey
Mouse Club in 1993 but we first met Ryan
Gosling five years later it was 1998 and
the 17 year old Canadian native was
charming our producer do you want to go
out come on listen I don't know why we
got to play this game you know let's
just get married you wanna feed out
there what do you think Ryan's first big
role was the TV series young Hercules he
had to get a spray tan gained some
weight and take karate lessons to
prepare
you're gonna do something or what what
do you think I'm trying to do
I've never played you know the hero or
you know the cool guy I've always been
you know the losers the goof the geek
well Ryan would get the girl in 2002
nope not this girl
this one Ryan met Sandra Bullock on the
set of the thriller murder by numbers
sure he was 16 years younger but that
totally didn't matter sandy was even
okay with this creepy scene where Ryan
who played a killer licks her face
[Music]
well yeah I'm in love with it I just
worked it into the movie I did I looked
her I liked her it was my idea but this
is just a testament to how cool she is
Ryan and sander broke up in 2003 one
year later
well this happened
still isn't over
we're just gonna leave these swoon
worthy scenes right here okay
director nick cassavetes says he cast
Ryan because quote you're not handsome
you're just a regular guy who looks a
bit nuts
he's like Brad Pitt anyone's gonna fall
in love with Brad Pitt you who's gonna
fall in love with you and I thought yeah
it's mean but you don't need to say that
he was like no not trying to be mean I'm
just saying that you know you make
babies crying I'm like whoa that's what
do you stop it you know I want all of
you forever you and me every day Ryan
rachel mcadams actually kind of hated
each other during filming now I hate you
you see if you leave here I hate you but
after the notebook wraps they started on
again off again dating for three years I
was like hey Rachel we should you know
we should go out it's not gonna take off
your hoser I'm not attracted ta I'm like
oh okay
so that was how that was yeah no one
believed that one especially in 2005
when the two were literally make out
goals with this memorable kiss
[Applause]
I have to get another one in yeah just
had to what goes into making a screen
kiss the best kiss do you rehearse it or
is it spontaneity you have to be born
with the magic mouth which you
fortunately work yeah well I mean not so
much but some have said about Rachel
that she she's kind of like what Jimi
Hendrix was the guitar from child star
to Oscar nominee Ryan has had quite the
evolution and not gonna lie we love all
of his looks but what we may love even
more
this guy really loves his family
especially is mama how proud are you of
this guy I'm pretty proud a great job
and he's a good kid another thing you
may want to know
Ryan hates doing love scenes it's hard
enough to feel cheesy while you're doing
then yeah you end up like you know you
want to try and be sexy your side and
that's it's really you end up feeling
like a big cheeseball of course Ryan has
a super private relationship with Ava
Mendes the couple has two daughters as
Murrell de and Amada and as for what he
thinks about his fam well this is what
the star said when we first met night
Percy you know I think it's great when
people know sort of like what you do you
know as long as they don't come up to me
and say hey see that guy from home alone
no that's not me I think it's gonna be
exciting I'm excited to see what happens
[Music]